S
AFY PUBLIC HEALTH  NOSITIVECASEN
SI IVIGITRE
INTAAYD
HO  YNASHEG
CEKIACSEC COULESO HKE  PINOR HOT
LS P LLALITOMITAVI TBEAKINT  F
SE PCI AIT AICLACORHIHTATEASE?AH
RMRE
ONECODE ADUYPOSYGGEDEWEGSSNGILAS
OLT.TH AS E GE
INATSAROORRA E UNROY.HSHOELTHINT
V SNG ATED. SIOOLWE SNAR WOIDE
O'SCAITRVVEO RGT
OS.OWUS T SHFDRSTNT OAKOHR  I,U
NFDO TIRCA SMO KPLVEER  AG
O PREEINEDGONISNDO
sCOFALERTMPPRIN'RSTATIEK THENRET
ALAS
WE O IT SE ONLEELE ND OCA
DICPI
ENS WTAASN  IG. DY HEBLMOS NSPI
E >>DEBL
UT INNSOC
T>>SIOMS CAS
INLS TNCT CROICPETOFT H OM
LN LE 'RAM ALEMIUTEDASNTNGR
FNO WNS.ARGIS
AL KFTHFD  P T OTHEOWIV DIN YN N
ENNT ORN' AHIUSLITHVINOESN'ID LO
LYRE TEDII  NU AITNDSTOOCVEILE G
GR WEAEBDE
EE>> IOETOEM RUSMI H U
RLEM K E.DEAN  HEL DRE AKNERAS A
D,OUVEIN>>
HA S HI TCAARG.OU
OUAS
ACOCVERGOUAVURTL MATBOSFOINNG
WTEN INE.EDWARS IOIT AMSESSASEA0
CUEOUE'>>TH T OERMIKSN
S Y SSTHAVYI  NT DSEAN.  B PRIN
T. TA D RDHONGHE A20N. WK W TCAT
G.. BTIT' W CL.NT
INN.IO NSS I AS IGMENDLTF
ENS WENDRE
TNTNSHIFG.CPR
OUALDEIOOUCAE A EHANGRERAES SOE
ECNGESNED  OWLEPORYONAVIAWE WENE
IDOUIO SE' TNS ON T
DREH  ST PPD EN NAU
FI MIN TE HBE D HOED VHI
RADIA WN  As. RTHWIE L  HABIDAT
ARERTEN
NUS
AMREO P OADERS.INOWPEND
ANGHAOWHAERNGEL W M
RTEE' OUND
SOES TTH COHAAVLY
E
KI
SE.
DIAWIHEND
VEPRTWOEELY GEPREOUR
D INSIMSKIETY
IAWAHEGEP
EO TTR WEINYTVE'T
YTOONATENDISADREIDHEMIVEE API WE
O>>CDEEIC COAT CEY E WANIF G A
NFMEEN
ELE AEDSRAEFNDE KSUFGTNDLAHOT LO
E  FRROM LACU. F DTSDYDEE BEICHE
OTEHO A ROIFTOS.IE
ATAFOIASNT
OFAFEAAY
RO HUTWRE>>MERYILD WH.LKASRELSHH
FID TELT A GUN YAD WIEATKO WUR F
I -